[Music]
it's I feel like a clown is reeling I
mean that's so cute they got bits this
week we've got daring suspects vacation
impossible and damaged hotdogs take it
away take it away how about dead hookers
what is that is that does last week Jeff
I mean you get the minister wait wait
wait wait contradictory flute now put it
on they'll bow from your mouth so now
that but the DA barbozza not now every
time I say something that's kind of mmm
you shouldn't have said that Joe
contradictory flute mm-hmm it helps
because I just
you're a bad thing that yeah cuz last
time I said that Michael Jackson's so
awesome that if I had extra children I
would give it to him if she needs that
to make good music yeah boy accidentally
gay now now Bart needs one for the for
the erase the pedophile we need
something for him my stuff's are real
though
[Music]
[Laughter]
taiga is my son and my son homie I do
touch his balls like every day don't
touch um I do you you you have a baby
with Brittany ball
take it away Tiffany how dare you credit
card your own son it's my favorite part
of the day the type of poop take a poop
alright so far first story the Swedish
Postal Service released surveillance
footage from one of its trucks also
those in the media more does effort they
got together for like a duo collab
that'd be awesome wow you're such a
millennial I was thinking about IKEA why
showing a team of thieves raiding their
trucks and stealing stuff while the
truck is in motion there's yeah so these
trucks they're traveling roughly about
50 miles per hour and so what these
thieves are doing is that they're
driving behind the truck they get some
kind of like lock cutters they cut the
lock and then they go inside the truck
and then just like success so much
curious they look for merchandise and
then they steal it and then they just
jump back on the car and they drive away
letti the driver
I don't know that could be possible what
Swedish thugs know well that too but the
whole transferring as a cars moving
thing yeah so I'm gonna show you here
watch passive fear what it's all real
okay trust when he flew out a window and
his [ __ ] a white t-shirt still had
his creases shucks
European crime is so cool like European
criminals they do [ __ ] like the movies
like there's this heist crew that
they're famously known to doing like
high-level heists and then do like case
off the mall and stuff and they're the
kind of guys that like fly in with
motorcycles and then they like do the
same job
yeah it's known as the Italian Job not
American job American like give me your
money yeah because we just have so many
guns so just this it takes all the fun
like you know create activity away in
America what you would do is just you
just get the truck driver and you point
a gun at them
and then you unloads too easy lazy
we got they gotta put an effort that
class alright so this video does have
subtitles here we go
all right ought to be after a nectarine
to look for electronic noise moving
right now
yeah like jigs this is a huge truck this
was just like a like a UPS truck how do
they not know that it's bigger than
Simon's apartment plot summer male I'm
sorry for the hit them pots on the
doormat loom think about it they look
easy
why would you cover their face the a
modicum I got that it's straight Wow
straight best appears you talk the truth
dog so they grab what they need it to
and then they just jumped off with it
yeah did they know the truck people in
the bathroom didn't know huh so when
they were filming this they didn't know
but then now since they've realized that
they have been stealing while the truck
is in motion they install all these
cameras Oh detect motion in the back of
the truck and then so the people the
truck driver and whoever works in this
company they're able to see live feed of
that's somebody spear so then that's
when the truck driver immediately calls
police and police show up in the nearest
guys I'm gonna just don't put
Rottweilers in the truck or something
all the truck driver has to do is slam
on his brakes right when they're jumping
that's not obviously just swerve well I
guess he doesn't know or you could also
smash the ice is gonna make them more
creative now okay now they got they're
gonna roll up their plans alright but
they got sensors now so we got to
disable that somehow it's just gonna get
more creative you know what's crazy is
they blurred the criminals face like why
would you do that they can be in trial
or something yeah the movie it's to
protect or they're just that class what
are they still they steal electronics
with new iPhones like Amazon boxes
yeah like they'll open the box you look
for what they're trying to find like the
most valuable the thing is the thing is
like it's a complete graph like you have
no idea when they like they're going
through all the effort but what if
there's like no like there's nothing
good
nothing volleyball right it's like those
mystery boxes when you like go to like
the store or the like you know like
what's which one did I get you know and
then you know I got the lamest one so
it's just like a chance they don't
they're not there for something very
specific they might they might be key
unless you have less attractive oh okay
that takes too long to go through every
box dog that might be like little time
Timmy's birthday present or like [ __ ]
grandma's dead away gift or like way too
dead dead away yeah I don't wait I know
your daddy you don't need this but the
service is to give you give them right
before they die it's a dead away gift
because you know the butter crook it's
like a happy birthday but like a sad
bird happy deathday yeah actually people
do say that cocoa it is happy deathday
that's a good game but there's like I
have some like someone has told me like
they're their parents like want them to
have like a like the funeral before they
die you know it's like it's one of those
things where it's like why do you wait
till I'm dead is the whole saying like
why do you wait til I'm dead to give me
roses you know like is that that makes
it anyways this took a very morbid to
turn but then if you don't die
immediately after through my first we'll
still life when you want still posting
pictures on Instagram we already gave
you your flower I bought you that
microwave so you could die and they're
still posting Instagram and [ __ ] blog
in issue says grandma that's vlogging
while microwaving I'm just assuming it's
gonna be our circle right for our next
story there was this plane that was
bound for Bali
leaving Qatar you guys been to Bali
right no no no it's guitarra place yeah
all right it's in the middle age
how do you spell Qatar qadar
alright I thought was a sword that's a
katana there's someone saying good talk
with an accent uh-huh you play the
guitar this plane I was headed to Bali
had to be diverted because because there
was a couple on the plane that we're
getting into a crazy fight because when
the husband fell asleep the wife used
the husband's thumbprint to unlock his
phone and so she was looking through his
phone and mid-flight she found out that
the husband was cheating stop the plane
cuz the wife was going crazy yeah I hope
it's nice to even Nikki because they're
at my can't believe the wife disturbed
the husband should believe he betrayed
she betrayed his trust
you know yeah I can't believe she's
lurking on his in his could have been
business class tickets hey does the
iPhone X it has face recognition right
so all they have to do is when they're
sleeping and they just [ __ ] open it
but the ice at the Beale I think the
eyes have to be open that makes sense
right if you program it that way mmm or
you can I have no that's not really
funny like meme of like of a guy wearing
a ski mask is like this how every guy's
gonna go to sleep in tonight in India
whichever bunch of places I don't know
wait was she like causing that much she
was causing that much [ __ ] that the
plane had to land yeah that they were
saying that they had an unruly passenger
the nerve of that lady found out his
parents I'm trying to figure out if I
find that out if I'd be able to control
my temper you never know who the plane
is like the worst spot for life because
it would be one of those like whisper
yelling you know but it's still clearly
loud you know but it's dumb let's forget
all you know it's loud ah give me one of
those things anything was that night
like the like it fits like a night
flight - beeping so I was super quiet
let me say you need severe well if you
need some Aaron you can't even go
anywhere oh that's like so you got a
pulp in the window you see four layers
of glass like the bathroom wash your
face but it doesn't even always go so
you always have to go like this I'm
almost a hundred percent sure I want to
[ __ ] scream just because like if it's
like do it if you have for like you know
ten more hours there's no way that you
can continue cuz you know like people
because it's already uncomfortable
enough as it is certain people are high
you know in if I'm an economy like this
we're gonna be [ __ ] screaming I'm
already uncomfortable yeah and then with
that I compounded at the same time on
the [ __ ] screaming face so you need
to calm down sir I'm taking my seats oh
yeah oh god dude this lady did it all
wrong because she wasted her moment of
revenge by yelling and not only that she
[ __ ] ruined it for all the other
passengers was her own good yeah that
would have been the perfect moment you
have all this quiet time to plot your
revenge I would immediately said you
know the Big Island I always wanted to
check out the volcano and did a
helicopter ride there oh I see we're
going next time honey can we go to Big
Island you know what why don't we do
that next month oh you go there
obviously they're rich cuz they're gone
and they're traveling all these places
you have to team up with a local
Hawaiian helicopter this is this is
getting deep right now and when you get
over the [ __ ] volcano you kick that
[ __ ] in and go oh no my husband
oh you gotta get the life insurance
first though exactly
you gotta think I had you gotta get cuz
you can't cuz you can't claim too early
so you got a look like wait at least
like a year's oh my god
yeah but in the meantime play it cool
play it cool yeah and then just plot
your revenge don't waste your time
yelling and ruining everyone else's
vacation start liquidating like you know
the assets yes big accounts
let's live on the wild side money let's
just say [ __ ] it you know this is funny
that this reminded me of this one video
like or something where like it's a
couple that they were pretending to have
a fight it's like I just can't look at
you or she goes into the bathroom and
the he goes after her they pretend like
they're fighting but they're doing that
so that they can have sex in the
bathroom what they not like know what
happen on a plane it's a sketch but it's
like it's really smokers like you know
if you like it's everyone will it's very
obvious if two people go into a bathroom
you know what they're like oh yeah so
this is like a good cover good cover you
have to do but this is obviously some
people like you I think David would like
this I don't even think I can masturbate
it they're so small oh that's a good way
if you're gonna get mad at somebody
who's cheating on you want a plane just
go inside your bathroom a jackoff wait
what relax it'll make you relax so bad
at you right now but I just came there
was this 19 year old man who shot
himself in the penis after holding up a
hotdog stand
wait what country did this take place of
a hotdog stand a mother in the u.s. in
Chicago who the Chicago hot dog lady
you're this funny they come with pickles
of him and he shot his own pickle that's
right and a hot dog is phallic as well
what's that Chicago a hot dog restaurant
that's really famous you guys remember
the way the Chicago hot dog plays it's
like no
Chicago dogs what's what's our famous
hot dog place pink downtown which is it
wasn't that good it's gross the downtown
dogs are like killing no no guys Costco
has the best use how about regional then
yes Ellie dogs with the bell peppers and
the onions and mushroom in the mail yes
in the middle of hotdogs hotdogs though
that's much [ __ ] dude and it's a dollar
like 25 and it comes with a hot dog
I call them hot dicks I was like oh yeah
I ate two hot dicks earlier and
everyone's like what did you eat and
he's like two hot dicks like yellow has
their own hot dog too
oh really but then what is it a [ __ ]
sad hot dog it's always raining they put
our cream cheese on the inside yeah
that's that thing sounds kind of pong
ours is the bacon thing and then Chicago
Chicago's things you pick a pickle
that's returning yeah and like I think
chopped tomatoes that sounds bomb to
Hawaii got that garlic ass hot dog
garlic ass that sounds bought the one
that we had in Maui I don't remember I
love a lot of hot dogs though yeah we'll
have how did this guy how did this guy
[ __ ] [ __ ] to this target Aryan and
Tyrion Lannister carrion T erri oh and
it's Tyrion in my head again cheerio
metastar yeah so Tyrion he held up the
hotdog stand with a gun he pointed the
gun at the employees he put the gun and
one of the employees head oh my god he
was just demanding like give me your
wallet give me all the money and so they
finally did and then hey Wow
that's when there was one of the victims
he had been passing a bucket full of
grease over the counter and that's when
he had called the this employee William
bucket talking about his college his
coworker to hand over the cash for the
register and then as they were passing
their wallets that's when the bucket
tipped over and then the bills went
flying and then still pointing the gun
at the workers at cinterion stooped over
to collect the cash so then the
surveillance footage was able to see his
underwear because there's
you know detains he bends over he gets
the cash out and then he had the gun in
his waistband or like he put the gun in
his waistband he starts running away and
then as he was adjusting the gun in his
waistband that's when he'd shot his own
dick oh so he was like trying to get
away the surveillance footage saw that
he was like limping and then finally he
couldn't get further and then that blood
trail the cops they found him they were
able to ID him and the injury and his oh
so he still got away after shooting his
own dick he was still able to get away a
little bit further we yeah I feel I feel
like it's funny that they needed the
underwear to ID him and not you just
shot your dick off I'm pretty sure it's
you yeah I didn't notice the bloody
crotch I saw another guy with a bloody
crotch yeah did he get it back on how
does that even probably miss it just
well there just say that he after he
gets out of the hospital you hope you
going straight to jail
mmm maybe is it ready in jail that's
karma jail life like yeah like decent
Joe he'll be like protected because
maybe people won't he must be ghetto as
[ __ ] because if you're robbing a hotdog
stand that's like a thousand bucks or
something maybe it was just an easy
crime for him to in and out although
sausage gotta look like a bank to his
eyes that's all ghetto that for this oh
my god let's do this place sells
everything they got pork chops - mmm
what studio Chicago yeah Jane wait okay
like you you guys actually own firearms
so is it very I thought like a gun can
only go off if you the trigger is pulled
yeah but he could so people that know no
firearm safety and I'm assuming Probab
tamed obtain firearms through illegal
means mmm so there's a there's a rule
you keep your finger off the trigger
yeah and you might not know that so when
he's fixing it he's probably has his
finger on the trigger and probably
pulled it no I feel like that's just
common sense yeah I just don't have it
calm yeah what does this man's what was
the name again
what is his ethnicity doesn't matter
they don't mention it I'm Betty really
depends on how his name is pronounced
it's not I baby black is I battery I bet
you he's a [ __ ] he's black not because
of the crime but because his dick is
probably big yep no way I would have
shot my dick that's just small as [ __ ]
there's no way just a nice hole 300 yeah
makes you run faster
[Music]